[Music]
what defines you
I ask first
there's nothing I wouldn't do for my
daughter
[Music]
Mrs Michaels Mr reckles asked me to give
this to you
[Music]
sorry ma'am the building's closed my
husband works inside I'm trying to reach
him I haven't heard from Owen in 24
hours
[Applause]
where's my dad
I don't know what is that
[Music]
[Applause]
you okay I can't believe this is
happening your husband is not who you
think he is why are you making him sound
like some criminal mastermind I may not
know why your father did what he did but
I know who he is he lied to me and then
he disappeared and I want to know the
truth
I'm telling you we'll find him
and I can need to get out of there now
where did you get this tell me who sent
you go now
and her stepdaughter are in imminent
danger is there something you're not
telling me they need to stay together
[Music]